and finally new rule an election is
meant to eliminate candidates
not voters last week in georgia early
voting in the wealthier white
neighborhoods in atlanta took just 15
minutes barely enough time for the
poodle and the car to get hot
but voters in some black areas stood in
line for up to eight hours
in texas the governor decreed that
there'd be only one ballot dropbox
per county which is fine for loving
county population 169
but harris county which includes the
city of houston
and has 2.4 million eligible voters
spread across an area larger than rhode
island
also got one box in some states you have
to put your mail-in ballot inside an
envelope and then put that envelope
into a second envelope and then sign the
envelope it's like you're doing a magic
trick
for people who say both parties are
basically the same
voter suppression is the stark example
that that's not true this is 100 percent
a republican thing
they know their policies aren't as
popular so they came up with an
effective
time-tested political tactic called
cheating
i can't make you want to vote for me but
maybe i can keep you from voting for the
other guy
that's their credo may the best man lose
anyway
the other night i was uh watching one of
those obstacle course shows you know the
ones where a contestant has to get
across a terrain of
giant bouncy balls and slippery balance
beams and swing on
friggin ropes like tarzan it occurred to
me while watching this
watching ricardo lose his grip on a foam
roller
that this is exactly what our voting
system has turned into it's american
ninja warrior democracy edition
try to move forward without getting
knocked off the voter rolls
match your wits and physical prowess in
our most challenging steeple chases like
the eliminator where you show up to vote
only to find your polling place has been
closed
splish splash you're taking a bath
or then there's the excruciator where
you finally find your polling place but
the line is hours long because they've
shut down
all the other polling places and your
precinct has been given the old broken
voting machines
kerplunk the misidentifier where you
finally get to the front of that line
that you've been waiting in
for hours and they tell you that you
have the wrong id
[Applause]
hope you can swim the monkey wrench
where you say okay fine i'll mail in my
ballot
only to find they removed the only
mailbox in the neighborhood
oh no and finally brand new this year
try to stay dry when going up against
the obstructor where you say [ __ ] it
i'll just drop
off my mailing ballot at a designated
drop-off box
only to find there's only one for 2.4
million people
it's amazing how brazen republicans have
become in
owning voter suppression back in march
when democrats were pushing for a vote
by mail
same-day registration and early voting
trump because he's a poker player who
always tells you his hand
said this would result in quote levels
of voting that if you'd ever agreed to
it
you'd never have a republican elected in
this country again
well not quite but yes more people vote
for democrats
a process known as counting
david lewis is a state rep from north
carolina
he was tasked with redistricting and he
gave one of the most honest rationales
for partisan gerrymandering mandarin
you'll ever hear
he said i think electing republicans is
better than electing democrats
so i drew this map in a way to help huh
well it must have been such a relief for
a cheater like that to stop pretending
that there was a good reason for their
cheating and just say it
like when mom finally admits that the
hitachi magic wand isn't for her back
well here's my
message to the cheaters i've always
preached on this show that you can hate
trump
you can't hate his supporters i meant it
then and i mean it now
but that goes out the window if you
steal from me
my vote is a thing of value you steal it
i do hate you because that's not
that's not we see the world differently
our politics are different
that's you're a crook a thief and a
schmuck
elections are supposed to be free and
fair not wet and wild
and if you wait eight hours to vote when
you get out of the booth
you deserve to do this
[Music]
you